best piece of advice would probably be
from lady gaga she said you have your
platform for a reason
do good and I was like okay when you're
young especially you have very low risk
and it looks great on a resume if you
fail even actually that you gave it a
shot so my family my friends telling me
to just go for it was really important
just work work really really hard and
don't give up I know that's really
simple but it works ignore all the
negative things that people have to say
to you and if you believe in something
or if you question something even though
everyone is telling you to do it
differently at least try your way and
see if it works give it a shot if it
doesn't you never have to look back and
say oh I wonder what would have happened
at least you tried a smile which is
which is crazy but I think you know
smiling every day and regardless of what
happens helps of perseverance helps of
being keeping calm under pressure and
just having a better perspective on
everything professionally or personally
don't ask for too much advice that's
kind of important
you